poupe l'idée que j'ai c'est avec une
grande plateforme participative internet
que nous lancerons le 25 octobre
dalé bâtir avec les français les
français qui aiment la france qui ne
veulent pas de cette société de l'argent
roi
dalé bâtir le programme comme un futur
de gouvernement le slogan de notre
plateforme internet c'est le pays avant
les parties du corps si les leaders
parce qu'on a quand même perdu les
élections vous comme s'en souvenir
si les leaders des républicains de ceux
qui restent parce que les autres ils
vont et c'est parce qu'ils sont d'accord
ils vont avec monsieur macro libre- s'il
est leader des républicains de debout la
france et du front national ne sont pas
capables de comprendre qu'il faut
réfléchir ensemble à l'avenir
et bien moi je vous prédis que la france
va coincer entre mâcon et mélange alors
à l'enjeu leur a laissé la france otages
d'un conflit mélenchon macron qui
aboutirent à la ruine du pays quel que
soit le président j insiste sur un point
c'est que si c'est pour reprendre le
même programme qu'en 2017
ça ne marchera pas et je pense que le fn
doit faire un pas vers l'est républicain
je pense que les républicains doivent
faire un pas parce que sinon si personne
ne fait de pas encore une fois on sera
dans les caricatures des caricatures